muhammad ali laid to rest friday as fans
gathered to say goodbye to the People's
Champ during a more than 2 hour long
procession et was on the scene several
famous faces came to pay their respects
including Whoopi Goldberg Arnold
Schwarzenegger and Katie Couric actor
Will Smith was a pallbearer
he helped carry the coffin to the hearse
before the procession what is the meteor
to be here today to celebrate the champs
life now yeah it's absolutely beautiful
the outpouring of love I learned a
really valuable lesson about how the
moment of the end of a light illuminates
how it was lived and the things that
were illuminated today where his love
and his heart and his his unconditional
appreciation for all people of every
race creed and color every age was out
there and it was beautiful it was
absolutely celebration was the right
word
as a man you know he just added an
element you know as an actor whenever
you play a role you always take away
something that lasts with you for the
rest of your life and I remember he
would you he would just walk away and
you look and he would just be in the
middle of a crowd of people no security
he just got on a bus he said I said to
him I said you know you just you just
walked into a crowd of people like what
you know you got on a bus and just rode
away you weren't going anywhere like
what what is that
and he said all man is so vain never
seen nothing like you before you got to
let them touch you know you real you
know and I just thought that was such a
beautiful idea that you have to let
people actually physically touch you you
know for the aspirational qualities
you